hello and welcome to cloud on air are
live webinars from Google cloud that
happen every Tuesday today we are
talking about the future of databases in
the cloud and my name is Deepti
Shrivastav I am the product manager for
cloud spanner so let's get started so
before we talk about you know spanner
and why we think it's the future of
databases in cloud I think it's
important to go through a little bit of
sort of how we got here right all of us
how how IT and databases in just you
know data itself got here
so for cloud it is still very very early
so most of global IT spend as you can
see here from from Gartner most of the
global IT spend is still on Prem and
very little of it in very small
percentage of it is actually in the
cloud so far right so most of cloud
growth is going to happen in the next
five to ten years basically right and
you
welcome back apologies for that and we
fixed the issue on our side so we'll
just continue right where we were and we
were very early in our presentation too
so it's not such a you haven't lost
anything if you're just tuning in
alright so we were talking about global
IT spend and how much of it is really in
cloud and as you can see from this chart
that we've you know got from Gardner
here from last year's Gartner reports
basically a very little of it is still
in cloud so each of these businesses and
each of these infrastructures have a
database right you you always need to
have a database to store your critical
data or not so critical data so for
database spend it's it's extremely early
in terms of cloud adoption right so as
you can see here first of all most of
database spend is an operational dbe's
DBMS is and very little of it is
actually in the sort of non-relational
open source world despite you know all
the sort of marketing you hear from the
non-relational side of the spectrum here
they're actually most data is actually
stored in relational databases and
that's sort of obvious right because
with the relational databases you get
you know transactions you get to Artemis
City of updates you get integrity of
data you get consistency guarantees etc
which are of course very very useful as
we all know for developing applications
so you know obviously this implies that
a lot of the database database is out
there and our relational and most of the
mission-critical data that is that a
company has will be stored in relational
databases so Before we jump into sort of
the growth of relational databases you
know it's important to talk about what
we mean by mission-critical right so
when you're talking about
mission-critical data what we really
mean is data that is you know business
critical right so loss of that data or
even
glitch in serving that data affects your
your reputation and has financial risks
to your company so all of this data that
is required for you to run your business
is what we call mission-critical data
and we're saying that you know most of
that mission-critical data is stored in
most cases in relational databases so
again where we at with the current state
of databases right so the most companies
as we talked about earlier right most of
the IT spend is still on Prem what that
means is that most databases are still
running on Prem and most companies are
then managing their own inflexible
database infrastructure on-premises with
you know an army of people trying to
maintain that infrastructure and
maintain their database and keep them
alive and running and you know of course
there's a huge overhead and having those
there are those companies who have you
know taking the leap and adapt adopted
cloud to some extent and what that means
is they're you know using infrastructure
as a service from cloud providers so
they're running their own database
solutions on top of these cloud provided
infrastructure so they're still in the
business of maintaining managing and
administering and keeping their
databases alive they may not need to run
the machines themselves that hosts those
databases but they still have to deal
with the database maintenance and
management and then there are companies
who are have taken a bigger leap where
they're actually paying a service
provider to manage and run their
database solutions in the cloud right so
this means that they don't have to worry
about actually keeping the database
alive there's a service that's doing
that but that still means that they they
have to make sure that the databases are
running the way they're that's expected
and they have to deal with the service
provider for their database service and
maybe deal with other providers for
other services right so there is some
complication there now apart from where
the the systems and the databases are
running the the other limitation is in
technology itself right so so companies
aren't
limitations around our DBMS scale up and
scale out and sharding solutions right
so if you run out of capacity of your
database what do you do right you have
to either scale up to bigger machines or
you have to sort of go to the Charlotte
solutions and they come with their own
headaches which we'll get into a little
bit and finally you know companies are
dealing with sort of the administration
and consistency challenges of scalable
solutions that are also no sequel or
non-relational right so for those
companies who already hit the the
problem with their databases and and the
scale of them and have adopted sort of
more scalable solutions that are no
sequel or non relational right there
they're trading off scale consistency
for scale or the traditional relational
semantics for scale they're running into
challenges of sort of having the
consistency issues and the challenges of
running and administrating these no
sequel solutions well they're on prem or
in the cloud right but the the
technology challenges still remain so
you know what does that mean
for for where we are in terms of the
spectrum of technology so you know we
have this very interesting trade-off
between traditional relational databases
and traditional non relational databases
right so on the business side right
traditional databases provide you with
schema with sequel with consistency and
the no sequel or non-traditional
solutions you know don't provide you
those but they trade those off for high
availability horizontal scalability
replication etc right which is the exact
limitations of traditional relational
databases in most cases what that means
is when you want to run high
availability relational databases for
your mission-critical applications you
have to create these highly complex
architectures to provide that
availability and replication and
disaster recovery solutions for your
mission critical data and as you can see
sort of you know you're running multiple
masters you're running read replicas for
you know scaling out and offloading the
the read-only
data-access etc you're trying to sort of
have men cash in there somewhere so that
you can do faster reads and writes re
reads of your data which means you have
to deal with the flushing of the cash
and you know you have to deal with
consistency issues with having multiple
masters if you need that you you have
backup replicas so so managing this
system now you've gone from one database
that hosts your mission mission-critical
data to this complicated architecture
that you know again requires an army to
maintain you don't actually know where
the bottlenecks are in some cases right
because the system is so fragile and you
know god forbid if one piece of it can
sort of somehow fails and then you have
to figure out what the cascade effects
are and in most cases you don't actually
even know what the full picture is
because it's become such a complicated
organically-grown beast so so going back
back to first principles right like what
do customers want what do you want from
your database right so obviously you
want it to be highly available and
scalable and you want it to give you
data consistency so you can access data
confidently for your application and you
can serve the correct and accurate data
to your customers right and of course
from from a developer standpoint when
you're building and using these
databases you want simplified operations
right you want standards you want single
points of contact for support you don't
want to have to talk to the database
provider and the infrastructure manager
and the cloud provider separately right
like you want to have one person or one
contact point that you can go to if you
have any issues so you don't have to
deal with crises by like being the
coordinator of various pieces in that
crisis right basically you want your
databases to run while you can build and
grow your application on your business
weight and this is where spanner comes
in so why did we build spanner and how
did we get here
right so so if we go back in time to
2005
you know technical infrastructure at
Google had various scalable solutions
because we had already reached the skill
versus consistency problem right so we
had scalable data storage systems but we
were lacking in transactions and
relational semantics in those systems
and as we've learned right as we all
know those relational semantics sequel
etc are very important and they really
help you run your business well so you
know Google reached that point and so
the need of the hour was horizontally
scaling databases brief asset
transactions and global consistency and
of course we are Google so we want no
downtime right we want high availability
we want you to be able to access Google
from anywhere at all times so we came up
with spanner we developed spanner with a
lot of research and a lot of
understanding of how to build
distributed scalable highly available
systems and what we have here is
basically the paper that we published in
2012 that talks about the technology
that we built at the time so spanner was
launched externally as cloud spanner
which is a publicly available product on
Google cloud platform and it's about
exactly a year ago that it was launched
publicly on GCP so we're celebrating our
first anniversary as a as a cloud
database so cloud spanner is basically
an enterprise-grade globally distributed
and strongly consistent database service
built specifically for the cloud to
combine the benefits of our relational
database structure with non-relational
horizontal scale so what does that mean
right we're basically saying you don't
have to trade off or make compromises
between relational semantics and
horizontal scale which is what
traditionally companies and
you know I team folks have had to do a
database users have had to do they've
had to basically trade off and give up
on relational semantics and build that
in the application to get horizontal
scale to manage their data growth over
the course of you know the data
exploding it for their business right so
spanner allows you to not have to make
that compromise it's are no compromise
relational database service right and
you get all of this packaged up in a
managed service so you can focus on your
database and not have to worry about
running so you can focus on the
application using that database and not
have to worry about you know running the
database itself so we provide you know
schemas as a transaction sequel and the
relational scale with up to five nines
of availability and an availability SLA
so we guarantee that we in a fully
managed easily scalable service so if we
are back to our chart of you know what
are the pros and cons of relational
versus traditional non-relational
services or databases right basically
you don't have to make those trade-offs
right we have schemas we have sequel we
have consistency like traditional
relational databases and we have
availability scale and replication and
by the way a bunch of it is out of the
box that you can get with non-tree so
tradition non-relational traditional
sort of no sequel systems so again right
you don't have to make compromises
between technical needs and business
needs in order to really run your
applications in your and your business
critical data now there are differences
right in in the technology of spanner
and you know traditional relational
databases and how they've worked you
know so far and of course you know there
is innovation here that allows us to do
this this relational with scale and I
can touch upon a little bit of that but
the important thing to note here is you
know like traditional databases do you
get tables you get DDL you get you know
the same sort of schemas that you're
used to so you do create table you
you know you have primary keys etc right
and in this picture you can see that you
know we've created two different tables
you know which are have relationships
that you can see and you use simple DDL
statements in order to create this table
and you know you'll use sort of this
sort of schema change DDL statements as
well to alter table or drop column etc
as well so again these are the familiar
constructs that you're used to so far
with the traditional relational that you
get with spanner as well with some added
benefits right so in this case you see
these two tables and if we were to see
how this logical structures laid out
spanner has a concept of interleaving
it's one of the many technical
differences but it's interesting to
point out as it kind of showcases how
you know we've been built for scale with
the relational term transactional
semantics so in the previous case we had
two different tables and they're
logically different right there's the
albums table in the singers table but if
you interleave the albums table in the
singers table what that means is that
the data is logically co-located right
so you essentially can think of it as a
pre joint so when you're doing large
data set reads or scans you don't have
to actually do the join at a runtime
right you can predetermine that these
data sets are going to be sort of query
together and you can logically tell the
system to store them together so that
they can be retrieved much faster now
you know for for a few Meg's or a few
gigs of data right like joining may not
be a latency causing issue but when you
have hundreds of gigabytes or hundreds
of terabytes of data and you need to do
all albums and all for all singers sort
of a query that's a lot of data to be
joined and processed at runtime at query
time so instead of having to do a join
at that time you can specify to the
system that you need to pre join the
data set because your most common
queries are actually going to scan
Stingers along with their albums right
so in this case the system can very
quickly you know basically read the data
and return the query result without
having to do the the computationally
intensive joint hence reducing read time
write a query serving time again you can
use interleaving for indexes as well so
you know we have secondary indexes we
are relational database and from that
standpoint you know you can of course
have you know separate logical indexes
which can be you know standard tables in
in in other traditional databases right
and in our kids they are standard tables
as well but you can interleave them
right so again if you're going to have
to back join indexes with the base table
because you of your most common queries
requiring that pattern then you can
interleave the indexes within the base
table and again that can lead to much
faster selects and queries of your data
so this is just one of the ways in which
spanner is different but it sort of
shows you under the covers like you know
the the technological differences we
have which allows us to provide scale
with relational semantics so you know as
Nick says in this you know quote from
Gartner so when we talked about you know
when we launched spanner and we talked
about it with various analysts and you
know of course we have customers that
are using it it's interesting because
you know it's not just another take on
the traditional database right it's
really a new way of thinking and you
need that's being met by the
technologies that spanner
but spanner is not just how software
right it's it's the combination of a lot
of very clever software which there is a
lot of along with hardware that we've
built specifically for you know scale
and and to provide the kinds of things
that we need for a large highly
available scalable system such as atomic
clocks that you know we have in in house
like true time is a technology we use
for global synchronization
and external consistency right which is
stronger than linearize ability so we
use true time which is based on atomic
clocks and GPS to do this coordination
and that powers sort of cloud spanner as
well and allows it to have that global
external consistency which allows us
that then have globally consistent and
strong you know strong relational
semantics database in cloud spanner and
this is of course built on top of our
Google Network which you know we've
talked about quite a bunch and there's a
lot of you know white papers that we've
actually put online as well that you
know one can read if interested but
basically it's a combination of our
Google networking which is you know
highly redundant and optimized on all
levels right from the network fabric all
the way to the to the switches to the
you know to the hubs etc and atomic
clocks and GPS with true time as well as
clever software in clouds banner itself
so you know we for example have wrote
our own implementation of Paxos we don't
use the open source PAC source
implementation we optimize the taxes
algorithm in our implementation for our
specific use case which allows us to
again do low latency transactions and to
do strong reads across continents and
across oceanic links and all of this
kind of combines to give you clouds
banner so there's a bunch of you know
customers that are using spanner and
they're excited about it and you know I
am personally excited to talk about you
know a few of them that I've been in
sort of seeing them win and it's really
exciting for us to see how the world has
adopted and started to use spanner right
so it's not just about you know trading
off capex for our backs right which is
what a managed database service gives
you that's kind of the promise of cloud
but with cloud customers are trying to
do inherently new and exciting things
that they couldn't do before because
they were limited by technology and in
this case
you know Activa which is a telecom
communications billing and charging
system so you know as mission-critical
as they get it has basically adopted
spanner as its next generation database
system for its next generation sort of
software - for billing and charging
right and you know when they looked at
spanner they saw you know improved
performance and reliability from the
existing traditional architectures and
they actually saw ten times more
throughput so 10 times more transactions
per second at a dramatically reduced
cost so ops Eve is actually presenting
this week at Mobile World Congress in
Barcelona and I'm here with you and I'm
not there but it's really exciting
because you know they're they're really
excited about the technology but they're
really excited about the possibilities
it opens up for them and for their
customers right and that's really the
reason to have sort of cloud spanners
and managed database service right they
don't have to worry about the system
itself and also because of its
combination of relational semantics and
horizontal scale they can do things with
this technology that they couldn't do
with their existing on-prem solutions so
another interesting example one of my
favorites actually Marketo and the one
following is again you know Marketo is a
marketing platform that you know
provides marketing applications for
companies all over the world right and
for them you know in their own words
right having order sequence in our
application logic is very in their
application logic is very important and
as they were looking to go to cloud and
looking obviously you know the first
step is you know which cloud provider do
I use in the second question for most of
us is well what database services do
each of these cloud providers have right
and and how do do I use them right is it
easier for me to use these services or
is it going to make my life more
difficult and with cloud spanner
basically again they could use the
system
to have the kind of order and sequence
guarantees in the app logic so they
didn't have to write brittle application
logic to have that sequencing right with
no sequel and with sort of systems that
are skilled but but lacking in
transactional consistency or strong
consistency all of that has to be built
into the app right which means your
application becomes a lot more
complicated and your team is basically
stressing in keeping that system alive
and running instead of you know building
cool things to serve your your customers
and you know that all obviously is a
productivity hit but also a growth hit
for you right it's a it affects your
business bottom line and in this case
when you don't have to worry about that
anymore you know you can choose spanner
you don't have to reap lat for more
think of reap platforming ever you just
grow as your global business grows I
mean that's a powerful statement right
and you know another one of our favorite
customers Evernote you know I think a
lot of people know Evernote again they
had a multiple hundred shard in my
sequel system you know they want their
users notes to be obviously available no
matter where they are and you know they
with cloud spanner can go to a system
that reduces this complexity gives them
scale and once they have migrated they
don't actually have to think about three
platforming again ever again right so it
reduces in fact eliminates all of that
stress of sort of managing the
complicated multi shard my sequel system
that keeps you know their operations
team sort of awake at night from from
that to sort of building more
functionality and having ease of use of
their their application and
infrastructure so you know we talked
about sort of the the positive things in
clouds banner or you know how it's
different from traditional relational
and non Ellucian databases but it's
important to note that Google cloud
platforms database portfolio is vast
right and spanner is one piece of it
right we actually have you know
memcache all the way on the left to you
know our sort of data warehouse in the
cloud with bigquery right so the way I
think about cloud spanner and bigquery
is you know if you're used to sort of
you know traditional relational
databases you know and data warehouses
right
clouds banner and cloud bigquery are
sort of the cloud equivalents of those
right but you know it's deliberately
placed next to cloud Spanos deliberately
placed next to non relational systems in
this chart because you know it allows
you to have non-relational scale right
along with the relational semantics that
it offers so you know the whole
portfolio basically allows you to have a
bunch of tools that you can choose from
to build the kinds of systems you need
right for your application right we're
not trying to tie you down to one and
only one solution but we're not giving
you through hundreds to choose from
right we think there are different use
cases that require very specific
tailored solutions for storage and you
know with this portfolio we basically
offer you a solution for each of those
specific use cases what that also means
is again you have the toolkit to choose
the right system but you're not left on
your own to figure out sort of rich
system you need to use among hundreds
right or dozens right there is as I said
a solution for each specific use case
and we help you choose the right system
for the use case so as this chart search
shows you know there's basically a flow
chart that you can use to pick the
system you want for the use case you
have and this is again up on our docks
in cloud.google.com so you can look it
up there as well along with a lot more
information
so hopefully that kind of gave you an
overview of why we think through clouds
banners the future of database systems
and we'll take a short break of less
than a minute and come back for a live
Q&A section as well so stay tuned
you
welcome back to cloud on air let's get
straight into our audience questions for
the day from this webinar so question
one
are you expecting all relational
databases to migrate to cloud
immediately absolutely not right like
there are many reasons why sort of most
of the cloud spend is still sorry most
of the IT spend is still in on Prem and
not in the cloud right as I had
mentioned earlier in my talk so if we
know that these are early days cloud but
what we want to make sure that customers
understand that they don't need to shy
away from adopting cloud because they
think they can't get the performance or
the semantics that they're expecting
from their applications in the cloud
right and you know if you're needing
horizontal scale and relational
semantics for example you know you don't
have to sort of worry about not being
able to do that in the cloud because you
know for example we have cloud spanner
on on Google cloud that will allow you
to have that without compromises so we
expect you know most of the cloud
migration to have in the next five ish
years three to five years and beyond
right there are many reasons for not
being in the cloud right now as I said
you know you you've already made
commitments you've already bought the
machines you've already got data spent
Center space you've already got color
space for your data infrastructure so
you know it'll take time but I know that
you know a lot of companies are looking
at migrating to the cloud and it's
important that they see the full picture
and all the options available to them so
that they don't have to shy away from it
for let's say performance or
manageability or any of those reasons so
moving on
why not just use a non relational
database on Prem or in the cloud right
so I think I touched upon that earlier
um you know if you want to use a non
relational database that's totally up to
you
however sure non-relational databases
come with the complexity that we talked
about right you know if you need
relational semantics and and most
mission-critical data does right like
bank systems telco systems health care
systems right when you need relational
semantics in
trying to use a non relational database
what that means is you've given up on
transaction in the system you've given
up on strong consistency you've given up
on structured data you've given up on
sequel sequel like is not the same as
sequel right anybody who's used a sequel
Lite system can know that it's not
sequel so you've given up on all of
those to get the scale with these
non-relational databases and if that
works for you great but but it does mean
that if you need those things you have
to build them in the application and
anybody who's even attempted to build
them knows that this is super
complicated code it's got so many sort
of edge cases that you have to you know
sort of think about and take care of
it's brittle because you know actually
building rolling your own transaction
then the application layer is hard
coordinate in the in the shard solution
for example right doing the logic to
join between two shards and you know all
those kinds of things are really hard
and again if you like doing that kind of
stuff that's great but for most people
they're trying to just you know build
their applications from their businesses
right and they don't want to worry about
these things in that case you know
non-relational databases just don't cut
it right for what they need okay what's
the difference between cloud spanner in
bigquery can't I just use bigquery um so
it's basically the difference between
all T P systems and OLAP systems right
so are you looking for an enterprise
data warehouse or are you looking for a
operational mission critical database
right that is literally when you would
choose one or the other cloud spanner
for all T P systems and you know
bigquery for OLAP systems so or
enterprise data warehouse so you know if
I were to think about it in in in the on
prime world or in the traditional world
you know it would be the difference
between Oracle or sequel server and
knitties our teradata right that's
that's the real difference and in fact
we're basically trying to make it simple
for customers to use their operational
data in a data warehouse with you know
cloud span or bigquery so you can you
don't have to like have complicated
tools for each yelling data out of your
relational database out of your
operational database and and moving into
your data warehouse right like there are
simple tools that we are working on that
will just basically allow you to quickly
transfer data from cloud spanner into
bigquery and then over time that you
don't even have to do the detail at all
it can be as simple as a push button
thing moving on this cloud spanner have
every feature that traditional databases
do I know right it's a different take on
the system so there are specific sort of
features that cloud spanner doesn't have
now that we're working on to fill those
gaps like you know DML obviously and
backups and sort of things like that and
and triggers and queues these are all
part of our roadmap right so so you I
would hope that our audience and our
customers give us you know some time
because you know we just launched last
year and you know traditional databases
have been around for you know 30 40
years so we're trying and moving very
fast and you know we're gonna close
those enter sorry those relational
database feature gaps that are critical
right there are certain things that are
not critical for relational databases
that are somehow are supposed to be you
know stored procedures for example right
that's just a way of pushing down
application logic into sort of the
database layer which you know we don't
actually think that's there the way we
want to go right with our system you
know we want to have a lean mean
database that can sort of do the things
you need it to do which is you know
strong consistency application
traditional sorry transactions etc and
we want to give this to you in global
scale right but we we think that
application developers know best how to
write their applications and and you
know that's the way we kind of want to
offer this service so we we've clouds
banner with a new take on databases we
were able to sort of you know go back to
first principles and think about why
databases exist in what they're needed
for what they're used for right and we
were able to cut out all the sort of
flack that has cruft that's been
building up in databases for a while and
we were able to go back to first
principles for databases and then
provide
you know the features and functionality
that you know are truly core for
databases especially relational
databases you know and as I said yes it
doesn't have every feature right now
which we're going to fill but it also
has features that no other relational
database or in fact no other database
has right which is global strong
consistency you replication
out-of-the-box and you know transparent
securities again built in in transparent
etc next question why is charting a
database so difficult um so you it's if
you ever sort of had to shard a database
you know this would be sort of an
obvious question or obvious answer
really so so think about a database with
a bunch of tables right and now think
about the fact that you can't actually
buy a big enough box to hold all that
data in all those tables so what do you
have to do then is and I'm gonna
simplify here there are many things that
go into consideration here but at the
simplest level what you have to do is
basically take the table if you have ten
tables take each table and then put it
on a different database right because
that way at least the data set for that
table is going to fit in your
traditional you know single box machine
so you have ten tables across ten
different databases so you you know it's
of course you can just keep using your
tooling and you can keep using
transactions all for within that table
or maybe two tables right with the table
and an index let's say right but it
behaves exactly the same as one database
for that one table and it's one index
right but if you ever have to do
anything across those tables then you
have to write the transaction logic in
the application to do the join and to do
the transactions on them right so you
essentially will have to write the
protocol to commit a transaction that is
done in a database inside the
application layer without having the
sort of engine that runs this system
right the database engine is what runs
these transactions etc and does the
consistency and guarantees etc so to do
that a neat application layer is
extremely hard and as I said very
brittle right because what happens
when you know one if you if you're doing
a two-phase commit for example what
happens if one shard is unavailable but
the other shard committed so do you roll
back that shard or do you retry on the
on the first stop a shard right and what
happens if you know during the commit
there was a network outage right so do
you know whether the transaction
committed or not right like how do you
recover from that state etc right so
there's many many things that go into
making a shard of databases sorry shard
database work well and all of them
basically make the application
developers live very hard so those are
some of the questions we had I don't
think we have any more questions so I
think we'll call it a day
and thank you again for watching and for
tuning into our live webinar as I said
we have these live webinars for cloud
on-air every Tuesday so please log in
next Tuesday for our upcoming webinars
on collaboration and productivity tools
as well as machine learning among other
topics thank you so much have a great
day